so um get your thinking cap on and um
get your pen out here's where we're
gonna start okay
uh you can make a little subheading this
is a proof
okay now i'm gonna give the proof to you
two ways it's a proof that unlike most
proofs you are expected to actually be
able to replicate
i'm going to give it to you two ways
it's a proof of
acceleration x double dot
in terms of displacement
and also velocity is what we will talk
about in a second
i'm going to give it to you backwards
first
um because i actually think the
backwards way is it makes more sense
and then second i'm going to give to you
forwards the way that you would actually
produce it if the question was
prove that and i'm going to give you the
result in a second okay
so here's what we're going to begin uh
i'm going to start at the end
okay so i'm going to say acceleration
okay what is acceleration
acceleration we said before we already
know what it is in terms of
time as a function of time so it's about
how
velocity is changing over time yes
but i said just now i want to try and
take this kind of equation
and sort of translate it if you like so
that it's not a function of time but of
displacement so i've got um
i just rubbed it off so i've got dxs
flying around rather than dts
okay so what am i going to do um you
remember we chain rule
right we're used to thinking of chain
rule as this um
you've got one you've got x and you
introduce some new
function right like so
okay but the key idea was that these do
you thinks right
they can you can shift them around and
cancel them and they're interchangeable
and that's what makes chain rule work
okay so i'm going to do something
similar here
now remember i wanted things in terms of
x's so i'm going to multiply by
dx on dx come in
yeah uh yeah
right where was i what have i done here
um answer not very much okay and it's
important that i haven't done very much
there's no net change just like with
channel okay i mean you can write this
as d y and dx times d u
of d u right it works because i haven't
actually changed anything
but now let's rearrange this so it's
actually something a little more useful
to us okay
i'm gonna swap around some of the
denominators and numerators okay
so let's put this dx over here i'm going
to get dv
on dx okay so i'm
switching around the dt and the dx on
the denominator
okay now what does this look like is
this any improvement
um it is a little bit okay because my
aim is to get rid of
the t's right so that they're no longer
in terms of time
but they're in terms of displacement
okay so you can see
here um
that derivative is something i know
right i recognize that and i can get rid
of the dt's because this
is velocity you see that the x dt
how x is changing over time so i'm going
to write this as v
dv on dx okay
thanks all right
now so far so good
um this is actually a helpful point i'm
going to come back to this line in a
second
because in a sense i have gotten rid of
my t's but i can go
a little further right this guy here
i i want to get it so that um i don't
have this bit here i want something else
um more in terms of the actual original
function okay
so i'm actually going to do a weird step
in here would you say that v
if i integrate that right with respect
to v
integral of v with respect to
okay what is that
good plus you're constantly of course
right now why is this useful you'll see
in a second
why but it's a bit of a strange why
would i do this okay
taking this that means that um v
is i'm going to differentiate both sides
now okay so if i differentiate this side
i go back to
what i was integrating and if i
differentiate this side i'm going to get
d
on dv of half v squared
plus a constant okay i don't forget when
i differentiate that constant's going to
vanish
okay so that's actually the derivative
of half
v squared okay so i'm going to take this
result which is
v okay and i'm gonna pop it in here and
see what happens
so i've got the derivative sorry
of half v squared
and i've got this other derivative
hanging off on the side
okay now why was this useful oh it's
just useful why is this a better step
than the previous one
because just like in
this line right what i've got is these
two um
differential operators right that here i
can cancel
right these two dv's they're going to
disappear because of chain rule okay
so this this dv and this dvd
are going to be no net change okay so
i'm going to get rid of it
but i can't just be d of whatever okay i
want to be d on something else and
what's left is my x right
so this cancels this cancels i'm left
with
d on the x of half v
okay that is x double dot or
acceleration
okay now this is the result
this is acceleration or force in terms
of
displacement right also velocity is sort
of
in there as well but we'll usually get
velocity as a function of x as i'll give
you an example in a second
so this is kind of cool right function
of displacement
so we're getting towards this kind of
understanding um these kinds of
scenarios where your motion is governed
by
how far apart things are rather than
when the time of the scenario is
okay but also i'm going to draw
attention to
this part here this is acceleration
as a function of velocity
okay now that's kind of useful as well
we're not going to dwell on this but
it's kind of an interesting result
that in the physical world you've got
objects that behave like this when
they're moving for instance
um when you throw something through the
air okay we've sort of been ignoring
this right but if you're going fast
enough your object right
it gets slowed down by the medium that
you're traveling to right like air or
water or those kinds of things
right so in other words your
acceleration
changes as your velocity changes okay
the faster you go
the more different forces like air
resistance are acting upon you
okay so you can get acceleration in
terms of
velocity how fast you're going or in
terms of where you are
okay